vous savez ce que c'est qu'un l'api de
monsieur c'est un clin qu'yves athlètes
levitte
c'est nul mais pourquoi raconter vous
toujours des histoires de 30 ans que je
n'ai ni nous ni permis de conduire
monsieur
[Musique]
leur jambon soir
qu'est ce que tu fais dans la vie je
suis viticulteurs ou plus évident dans
le var tu as beaucoup d'ex tard
roosevelt n a pas mal ça quand même non
oui ça suffit ça suffit pour gagner
combien par mois pas beaucoup c'est à
dire très peu c'est pas chez les
personnes non mais il peut écouter sait
jamais avant pour être strycek technique
à cela mais jamais au grand jamais
qu'est ce que tu fais comme ça mais je
fais du côté de provence mauvaise
réputation que pensent les gens qui n'y
comprennent rien qui narre aussi ceux
qui n'apprécient pas la côte de provence
sont tous des gens qui ne l'ont jamais
goûté ou des gens qui n'y comprennent
rien
qu'est ce qu'il a de bien côtes de
provence à comment tu le vendrai ont le
vent en leur faisant apprécier devons
allons-y avec plaisir
voilà
pour nous c'est vrai
il est même beau voilà ça vieillissait
20 pas très longtemps un de deux ans
maximum
ouais par contre les rougerie c'est
beaucoup alors aujourd'hui le côtes de
provence et mauvaise image c'est dû à
quoi être pas très bas une nouvelle
information d pas ouais
et peut-être un passé qui n'a pas
toujours été l'un n'a pas toujours été
aussi bon que maintenant depuis dix ans
ont fait de gros efforts de qualité on
diminue le rendement pour que les vignes
produisant moins sur mesure pour les
méthodes de vinification ont été changés
améliorée je crois comme on en est
arrivé au top
ouais on se permet de gagner de pas mal
de médailles dans les concours on est on
est après chig et ça vous convient une
bouteille de côtes de provence pourrait
que les gens se fassent trop arnaquer la
laiterie bâtiment restaurant et c'est à
dire il ya un prix à la production en
brisant la version 1 to est une vont
commencer demain qui vaut 17 francs 50
dans la bouteille tâche est en récession
et dans ce restaurant je peux l'autre et
combien ce vin 70 francs prélevé au
championnat en plein fouet et dis moi tu
vois autre chose que du fait de
prononcer je vois tous les vins oui mais
je bois tous les jours au moins une
bouteille de couteau devant une
bouteille déçu et ça te fait quoi
ça me fait du bien alors bien sûr c'est
très bon pasteur a dit que le vin est un
aliment
ah bon oui et les campagnes anti
alcoolique cette gêne pas toi ça me gêne
beaucoup parce qu'elles sont très mal
faite
ils font des campagnes contre
l'alcoolisme en faisant voir sur les
affiches et les télévisions que des
verts devaient alors que
la festi ce qu il ya de pastilla luis
kia les alcools l'étranger et alors on a
demandé à certains publiciste pourquoi
du vin n'est pas autre chose
il prétend de simplement que c'est parce
que berlin rouge ressorts mieux à
l'écran ou sur la fiche kriss est dure
pour eux ça voilà c'est dur fait à tes
parents tes seins déjà mes parents de
ses grands parents aussi
mes grands parents aussi c'est une
tradition familiale oui et j'espère que
la descendance pendant la suite ça se
passe comment la vie pour toi ça se
passe bien le matin par exemple les
acquéreurs mais ça dépend de la saison
oui disons qu'on a tendance à se lever
avec le jour dont la semence et syncreon
le matin en temps normal lorsque l'été
est un véritable hit est pas qu on veut
se donner
on travaille de 5 heures à midi c'est
bien beau vidéo fait la sieste quand
même oui quand même récupérer ce
qu'assure hydrater et alors sinon tu vas
le soir tu vas voir tes copains comment
ça se passe non j'ai plutôt les copé qui
viennent vous voir viennent chez toi
voilà hélas alors quelquefois bonus et
quand tu vois quand tu vois arriver les
parisiens étaient tu en penses quoi là
c'est difficile à dire tu peux le dire
oui bah disons que les parisiens ils
sont formidables
kadi sommes pas chez eux enrichissons
sympas ils sont neuf à quinze sont
décontractés la ramène pas essayé n'ont
pas trop jeune tandis que cannes aura
choisies sont et supporter mais une
autre est de culture heureusement mais
surtout dans les rues de paris canales
voilà nos voitures immatriculées 83 7 à
puis l'accent c'est tout de suite le
notre bonheur tu regrettes quoi la
provence d'avant je regrette
on n'y a rien à regretter ce qu'on peut
regretter c'est que que la provence
notre terre ce soit urbanisées peut-être
un peu vite j'ai un peu maladroitement
on a vu du béton partout ça c'est le
foot c'est donc habiter ici nous qui
l'avait laissé faire ça chez nous c nous
puisons il ya des gens qui ont maintenu
des terrains une parce que à la suite
d'événements familiaux des familles qui
s'arrêtaient de travailler la terre ou
autres qui ont maintenu puis les
personnes et que d'acheter ont revendu à
des promoteurs ne peut pas arrêter la
chose toute façon il faudrait sur la
maîtrise et la provence elle existe
encore elle existe encore certainement
si tu devais définir la provençale c'est
quoi pour toi
[Musique]
la mas provençal c'est là qu'elle
accueille
l'amabilité
l'amitié qu'on essaie de faire partager
et de recevoir on donne beaucoup
novembre et puis peut-être la
décontraction mais pas autant que ce que
les parisiennes peut être dit que les
parisiens quand ils disent que et une
sardine qui a bouché le port de
marseille se fout de la gueule des
provençaux à côté de ça je pensais pas
vrai ils n'ont rien compris ils n'ont
rien compris c'est un fait véridique qui
s'est passé le port de marseille a une
petite andrée quand vos besoins de porc
joe est un bateau qui s'appelait la
sardine et qui a coulé dans le passé
cela alors la sorte il a bouché le port
de marseille
et là ça a suffi pour que les parisiens
10 alors que nous exagérons tous un peu
vrai mais toujours et ils ont bien vu
que c'était une sordide et qui avait
lâché le morceau beaucoup de choses
comme ça sur la provence qui sont
racontées qui sont carrément reçu pour
votre tonique
les provençaux se lève à midi pour boire
le pas si ces jours au boulot c'est faux
ils ont fait leur bonheur seulement les
parisiens qui sont à ma case qui ne se
lève à 15h30 ne nous voit qu'à l'heure
du pas si c'est de la pétanque
tu crois qu est ce que tu veux redire
est aux parisiens qui viennent en
vacances d'été dans le var en provence
je le redis avec wall a promené à mieux
nous connaître vous êtes prêts à les
rencontrer
on va bien sûr devant un verre de rosé
ou plusieurs verres de rosé
voilà il pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je
m'étais un peu ce bleu